LETITIA WRIGHT
Hey everyone!
We're the cast of...
WINSTON DUKE
And it's time for one of my
favorite parts of the job.
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Unboxing some really cool products
inspired by the film.
[Gasping]
[Laughing]
LETITIA WRIGHT
Oooh!
WINSTON/DANAI
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
Look at this!
I want to have this body!
[Laughing]
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Whoa! [Laughing]
Funko Pop!
[Laughing]
Mah fah...
Your head size matches.
[Laughing]
RIRI WILLIAMS
Go!
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Got the removable visor!
LETITIA WRIGHT
So this is an aircraft called a Sunbird,
created by Shuri.
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
My throne! Bend your knees!
DOMINIQUE THORNE
Oh! That is incredible!
LETITIA WRIGHT
Kimoyo Beads!
The detail, the Wakandan language...
I love it. I'm taking this home.
TENOCH HUERTA MEJÍA
I can keep it, right?
DANAI GURIRA
Come on girl, let's get out of here.
WINSTON DUKE
Wow!
SHURI
Yes!
LETITIA WRIGHT
Make sure to go and see our new film...